[Musica]
[Risate]
no no no non è troppo ma no no no non
entrò paura no
inutile che ci spinge carla no facciamo
così se c'è qualcuno in sala fatto un
countdown
aiutatemi contate da 5 fino a 0 invece
le zero ditte via tipo 5 4 3 2 1 via
vico e via io prendo coraggio entro
proviamoci trotti 5
[Applauso]
quante volte vi capita anche movimento
del genere quando quando dovresti fare
qualcosa è ti blocchi di blow chiesta da
fermo a riflettere la riflessione può
essere tipo ma perché io cosa ho fatto
per tentarne così tanto forse non sono
quello giusto
forse non è il momento giusto e
cominciare a riflettere come uno
specchio
se ti guardi e ti meriti e ti guardo e
divertiti guardi diventi quello e diane
vuol dire fare un passo per avere il
coraggio di uscire dalla in finire qua
quello che potrebbe essere il vostro
passo da qualche parte quando vi capita
un'occasione e voi cosa fate
riflettete questo momento un metodo
fantastico e il metodo canale 5 secondi
contate dentro di voi che fate 5 4 2 1
evvai perché se tu vai non ha il tempo
di riflettere in mente è creato tutte le
tue convinzioni limitanti the dirty è no
ma perché sì però non ci sono oggi
comincia domani ingredienti
domani la prossima settimana faccio
ricorso più fatto in inghilterra e e
alla fine di mani da fermo e il
cambiamento che cos'è il cambiamento è
semplicemente aggiungere qualcosa e la
tua vita per il coraggio di fare
qualcosa per andare verso dove qual è la
direzione e quelli credo che ognuno di
noi della the una direzione ma come fai
a scoprire la direzione allora prendo
spunto da un film the prestige di cristo
fa nulla
è un film eccezione delle giovani a chi
chiede un mago saggio come funzionale
magia le bambine e curiosa vuole sapere
come come tutti noi con dove vanno a
finire curiosi e quello che vi chiedo
oggi è di ritornare bambini tornate
bambini tornate a stupirvi ritornati a
guardare le cose con me
quello che abbiamo fatto noi
entrando mai considerato che questo
libro fai quando sei bambino quando sia
due pretendenti a darti cose da fare che
non hai neanche il tempo di arrivare poi
a guardare e diremo che bello dc dai su
fa veloce che alessandro di così rimasta
voto servono in discoteca e non hai
avuto il tempo di di stupirti ecco
tornate bambini tornate dosaggio come
funziona la magia in questo modo saggio
gli rispose che la media è composta da
tre parti la promessa ascolta e in
prestigio ma che cos'è la promessa è la
promessa è una cosa che si fa quando sei
bambini in una grande cosa vuoi fare da
grande tipo non so voglio fare
l'astronauta voglio fare a fette di
napoli sono dei bambini che dicono cifra
pari a un tolo go
bene che cosa fa promessa non è una cosa
che nessuno ti cultura dici ok ti stai
esponendo e poi ti esponi mantenere le
promesse date il voto non ti esponi
quando torno 12 sono due aspetti ma
vediamo come va va
e poi magari la vita non vale la
televisione detto volevi fare le
direzioni che vogliono gli altri
ecco perché è bene da promessa perché il
momento in cui tu prometti e non prove
di kamata di persone e si quasi
costretto a mantenerlo pd ti metterai
alle volte in difficoltà per riusciranno
a tenere nel promesso e dato trovate
alta in sala
promessa avete pensarci tramite evidente
adesso subito così alla nostra promessa
che domanda così
pensateci la vostra frusta cosa certa
azienda cosa promette un cliente
importante perché si dimentichi questa
cosa qua tu rischi di far le cose tanto
per farle una volta che ha fatto la
promessa ci volevano svolta perché non è
che puoi promettere puoi tirarti
indietro non farete niente quanto
prometti poi devi fare un qualcosa di
diverso il cambiamento cambiamento
sottofondo di aggiungere ceccano inviare
cambiare la tua vita fare qualcosa di
diverso qualcosa che non hai mai fatto
fate qualcosa che non avete mai fatto
perché ti apre un mondo e la svolta e
questo cambia quando per andare verso il
prestigio a livello in prestigio
prestigio per quanti di voi prestige una
cosa bella alzate la mano sbagliata
prestigio deriva dall etimologia in
inganno
e secondo voi inganno una cosa bella una
cosa brutta
tra quanti riguarda cosa brutta inganno
sbagliato
l'inganno non è bello non è brutto
dipende dalle intenzioni che ci metti il
prestigiatore chi è il prestigiatore lo
dice la parola stessa il prestigiatore
colui che inganna ma al motivo valido
per stupirli nel mio caso per stupidi ed
ispirarmi e questa è la parte frontale
quali la vostra intenzione perché fate
quello che fate perché lo fate
chi è dentro quello mamma e quando fate
da mangiare i vostri figli porta da
mangiare perché ho l'ho fatto perché la
vostra intenzione in mentre il vostro
figlio pensate che differenza
l'ho fatto perché dovete arrivare alle
otto di sera il vostro lavoro l'ho fatta
perché volete che cosa c'è di venire da
voi come come dovrebbe essere
ecco questo è l'intenzione perché fate
quello che fate prenderlo
vi faccio un esempio tramite questo film
the prestige dove la bambina che dalmato
saggio come funziona la magia e il mango
saggio glielo spiega poste esempio il
famoso gli dice che ogni numero di magia
è composto da tre parti o atti e la
prima parte
l'illusionista mostra qualcosa di
ordinario mazzo di carte una bustina di
zucchero vi chiede di ispezionarla di
questo ma ovviamente è probabile che non
sia il secondo atto la sua volta il
regista prende poi qualcosa di ordinario
e lo trasforma in qualcosa di
straordinario ora voi state cercando il
segreto ma noi lo troverete perché in
realtà voi non state guardando voi non
volete sulle auto nei tessili internati
e ancora non applaudite perché far
sparire qualcosa non è sufficiente no no
no no bisogna anche fanno apparire un
rimedio è composto da un terzo atto è
l'atto più importante è l'atto che noi
maghi chiamiamo il castigo
bravo ci sono state molte basta poco
studi ci vuole l'intenzione la mia
intenzione è quella di ispirarvi voglio
fare una cosa che è comune su un esempio
lampante che alle volte il cambiamento
si può fare attraverso il countdown per
che contavano le fondamenta di 5 4 3 2 1
fi
non state lì a pensare fi cioè non
provare fare fare fare lo direi per un
quarto d'ora ma note fare fare il
fantastico c'è stato un mio caro amico
che oggi è diventato un personaggio
famoso si chiama è rimasto in america è
considerato le redini degli anni duemila
chi era elio dini era il più famoso
escapologo il mondo scelte l'escatologia
l'arte di evadere da qualsiasi
costrizione camicia di forza acate le
manette ma ogni suono
quando mi regalo questo questo e questo
fa mi disse walter io parto per la torre
a silla conosci qualcuno che possa fare
l'escatologia al posto mio
lui mi guardò e disse non conosce
nessuno io vivo a me ma tu fai le cose
comiche non lo puoi fare una roma così
seria e questi tu non lo puoi farlo non
posso capire se sono capaci di farlo
adesso che le lunette in a catena tifa
incatenare troppo se ce la fai
chiedilo a tecnico cresce gente scienza
ma non è semplice non ce la fai fa
niente il numero dello zucchero verrà
terno
tutto ha bisogno di due esistenti e cosa
succede siccome quando sono arrivato qua
ho visto che c'era troppo spazio
ho già trovato delle persone ti chiedo
con un grande applauso di venire qui
silvana grazie ti chiami andrea da
questa parte grazie al ti chiami loris
da questa parte il compito vorrebbero
fare milioni di persone incatenarmi
tieni questo lucchetto chiudilo e
controlla che non si possa aprire una
volta chiuso ok non si può aprire sicuri
controllato bene che bisogna essere
sicuri
ok quindi lasciate luckett aperto
togliete la chiave mi mettete la chiave
dentro la scatola buttate là dentro una
vai anche tu chiudi una scatola perché
non voglio che colgono pensi di orgoglio
bla della città delle luci di quindi
sono veloci dopo di che ti chiedo di
controllare queste catene
ok controlla che non ci siano buchi
guarda incrollabili buchi
era seguito da trapattoni catini siano
regolari ma ti chiedo una cosa in più
vedi che qui c'è una saldatura
controllate la saldatura non si possa
aprire fatto tutto perfetto quello che
ti chiederlo a te è quello di io mettono
le mani così e turi chiuderai il tutto
ok ti chiedo una cortesia di prendere la
giacca di controllare che non ci siano
chiavi all'interno sono attenti e facile
io stop perfetto ho ripreso un compito
molto particolare quello di darmi una
mano di file in canada intanto badolato
chiudere più di qua stretto guarda se
poi più stretto 43 che troppo mozzi si
ok va bene era buono però mostra ecco un
respiro ma va bene grazie consegna pure
la giacca aimi controne che lui che
magari io non sia uno che ha fatto
qualcosa di più di quello più sopra
guarda se no troppo poco prevede proprio
per prima ok piano che c'è il nostro che
si chiama radio così la rompe non si
sente
ok
scenderei per farti controllarla
guardate attentamente guardate chiuso da
una parte non ci sono spazi chiuso
dall'altra controlla che il suo
l'occhietto si è fatto bene chiuso
ok controllarti il suo sensato bene più
vasta
grazie nel tipo di guide è perfetto ora
prendiamo la giara avete controllato che
non ci sia niente ti chiedo di prendere
questa manica qua ok con la mano destra
e questa mania quella mano sinistra
la manica né manica fermo così
attenzione ora prendi l'orologio e
mettilo così in maniera tale che posso
darvi anch'io controllare i secondi
quanto tempo sto perché perché è il
liutista un minuto e 22 secondi per
liberarci dalle catene rubato batte il
suo record in un minuto e 12 secondi io
walter clean con questa sera per voi lo
farò in un ora se era un mago lavoravo
las vegas
no a tedesco
quello che vi chiederò a proposito tutti
ogni tempo con l'altra mano
ok 123 quando avanti quel conteggia tu
con ok
il vostro compito è questo e quello di
di aiutarti ok
da qui il coraggio ok mi farete un
countdown dai 5 al gillian come prima
io metterò le mans 8 e cercherò di
liberarmi nel minor tempo possibile
ok d'atmosfera
passiamo un pronunci casi basta così
dovete sapere che lascerà
[Musica]
prendo sempre spunto da questa cosa per
fare una cosa molto importante nel mio
modo di fare spettacolo
questo è il metodo che mi permette di
ringraziare le personalità che si io
sono su questo cerchio rosso e perché ci
sono delle persone che lavorano nella
parte oscura ci credo che se invece di
aprire quella dove sono venuti prima era
preparato il teatro quello che mesi fa
ha cominciato a fare la pubblicità per
gli che hanno organizzato tutto tutti
quelli che sono partite non si prendono
un applauso perché sono dietro le quinte
io invece vengo qua e trovo tutto pronto
mi prende l'applauso quindi un applauso
a tutti coloro che fanno qualcosa per
voi in qualsiasi posto in qualsiasi
ristorante in qualsiasi hotel e qual sia
qualcuno che lavora per voi e ne sono
grato profondamente spirito di niente
sul gra dojo assolati pronto contare i
secondi tulli contrae sarai 123 lui
ok per chi non sente farà vedere quel
display
mi raccomando voi se funziona ti
piacciono
quando vivo in via fatte 5 tutti tutti
tutti tutti a rovigo vi amo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
comincia a contare con i secondi quelli
piccoli sono un attimo signori sono
sfidati mo sto spiegando scusa li scuse
per cortesia toasted devi dire forte
sono ok perfetto di 54 controlla bene
anche con dada anche se magari una mano
e libera che nei suoi magari anche
l'altra mano e libera forse il pubblico
applaude perché mi sono allenato
[Musica]
grazie grazie veramente un applauso
bellissimi liberabili bene catene del
passato e l'asma il futuro che desideri
e nel mentre di
[Applauso]